middle-class famous tour gang is coming
to a town and near you oh yeah nice mix
of stand up play a little ayg with the
crowd it's a good time good way to
introduce people to the show bring the
homies bring the bozos bring your guy
bring your gal bring the whole [__]
squad yeah guys we introduced a whole
new set of cities we got buffalo
pittsburgh detroit red bank new jersey
seattle portland kansas city springfield
st louis nashville indianapolis get
those tickets come out with the boys
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out the
group to be classy yeah they're just a
big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
aunt toddy's basement she's down the
beach for a week okay so every year her
and the girls they go down there about
15 of them they get a hotel room yeah
[__] tear it up for the week you know
how it goes i'm not talking about
reading to john grisham on the beach
okay talking about [__] titty
contests and doing [__] speed okay
letting it all hang out down there that
sounds cool
a couple of joining rooms too i'm sure
one for the watchers my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he's
my best pal in the whole wide world he
is the prince of park avenue but always
the king of the boards
give it up for kj kevin james ryan the
kipparino the king of the boards that
was a that was the name at the beginning
of this show we were doing kippy it was
king of the boards
wild new jersey where this all started
on on my mom's couch which you were for
a minute weren't you the king of the
boards or you had the body surfing or
you ate the most calzones or something
like that what'd you do
you headbutted the most seagulls
fought the dunk tank guy more than
anybody
in wildwood new jersey no it's getting
the boards i did the uh the quarantine
down there is the only guy on the boards
for [__] months that was the only guy
in that goddamn damn had that whole town
to myself toughest guy at the gym over
here huh
squatting 150. i was working the bucket
toss and throwing it you know what i
mean how about a nice quick shout out to
our producers i don't even get to do any
uh hold on any of the plugs i need a
business that i've got that was so
perfect though yeah so we got the new
headphones we're zipping around we're
coming
i don't like them and toe t-bone's gonna
be pissed they're huge on you by the way
uh again you're wearing two satellites
so i'm telling you it's the same ones
you have on
i look good though right
guys make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are true hook
it up
and then the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com get a bajillion dollars
of content do it that's where all the
action is over there on that patreon we
threw a couple things out there let them
peek over the fence a little bit we
throw hard feelings out there on the
youtubes uh people loving it and hey
people like you guys are so mean to each
other i'm like the show's called all
hard feelings what do you want from me
it ain't called ain't called hugs no
it's not those warm fuzzy feelings it's
where the [__] we let it all hang out
and come see us on the road we're going
to be in red bank we're going to be got
some new dates at it there new dates
coming out we're going to be uh red bank
new jersey red bank news
going out there comic books and [__]
long dusters okay can't wait to get out
of here apparently that's a nice town
red bank yeah it's nice out there okay
now back to t-bone as i said i apologize
for interrupting sir he's the brains
behind the operation he's the magic man
makes us all look good he's a god i've
got these new headphones i'm telling you
right now give it up for toby mcmullen
everybody what up dudes
we love the headphones the headphones
are perfect sound really good i don't
know it's funner if you say you don't
like him and t-bone loses his [__] and
that's kind of the character i'm playing
i looked at so many [__] headphones
it's the only piece of technology that
gets bigger the more money you spend i'm
going to see how uh how things play out
because
i'm going to see how things play out
between me and t-bone
determine what side you're on to
determine whether this is how nuts you
are by the way i can be bought i know
yeah tell you that right now sometimes
you get bored and just rustle up a fight
i had kippy turned his head on a couple
of breakfast tacos this week see what
can you do for me toby that's what i'm
going to say oh right here going out no
it's okay
sounding good yeah gang it's a [__]
family episode damn damn just the boys
just the homies just the bozos we're all
hanging out we're gonna be answering
your questions i have something i gotta
run by you which you're aware of i'm
here buddy but it made me think of a
question okay
um
how long is too long
this is never good coming from you to
not brush your teeth
now we had a great comp on he went six
months obviously that's that's that's
nuts
but for a normal person i don't know i
did a bad situation i would say a trip
to l.a for a monday to thursday that
would be my guess that that is the the
length
you should you should brush your teeth
it's funny you mentioned that's why i
brought it up yeah kippy and i were out
there on the coast i got out there into
the hotel room um
and i didn't have any toothpaste which
probably you had it because you always
come to me and now
no
anyway i was out but good good thing my
good pal gippy was on his way to
7-eleven to get his afternoon taquito
fix
i had
we were [__] jammed up out there
chargers at 7-eleven man you're hurting
the guy's like what do you have an
iphone 4s i'm like what the [__] still
got the big jaw and the big plug at the
bottom all i got is 220. we left our
radio shack guy back i know toby's
cable's on the road toby cables
um
you ran you got me toothpaste i it was
very early in the morning about six
o'clock in the morning i got up couldn't
sleep but jet lag down there playing a
coast back and forth like one of the
numbers like we do we're in there like a
detective we were upside down on that
trip um
i uh i ran i said hey i'm going to
7-eleven do you need anything
you said get me some toothpaste please
um get you the toothpaste
then i don't see you yeah i forgot about
it no like i get it's in my room but
then like it's like all right we're
gonna meet it too or whatever downstairs
no like i'm gonna pop down what room i
would have to pop up yeah i thought you
were gonna drop it off and i just forgot
about it and then the next day
turned into the next day yeah the next
day the turn and the next day yeah so
what i did was also the bernies were how
do you put it plentiful on this trip
ripping heaters
a lot of [__] eaters a lot of coffee
yeah my breasts a lot of mexican food i
was making my cpap machines think that's
that's how bad my breasts quit midway
through that's it i'm not even they have
toothpaste at the i know i i just got
that we're out in l.a we're hopping
we're singing we're moving around we're
trying to be homeless
you know i just forgot about it the way
i got school we're meeting all these
cool influential people and you got
[__] gout in your mouth how are you
doing
ah
no the h is for halitosis we were uh
i was drinking he caught me sipping i
wouldn't i would have laughed now
we were out of there usually early in
the morning and gone for most of the day
uh except for the 15 hours i slept in
the hotel room um man this guy could put
a nap down
literally thought he died two days two
days in a row i'm calling i'm texting
i'm about to send [__] security in to
ram the door but anyway snoozing i got
by i would just you know there's like a
little bit of toothpaste on there on the
brush if you wet it
if you're wetting i mean like the caulk
that forms like a third of the way down
you put a little hot water on that yeah
that reanimates that'll cream up for you
yeah you'll get a little mileage out of
it but i got a couple of brushes out of
that and i just went i figured that
loosened up you know whatever was in
there loosened up the the rocks and [__]
that are in there and then i rinsed my
mouth i left the smell out
really unclogged the pores gargling with
febreze keeping it moving but then i
just i just did heavy on the gum i just
went i just two pieces also in your
defense we spent the whole week together
made out a couple of times i didn't
notice
you didn't notice uh-uh that's good
that's good but what is this that's a
testament just how you smell all the
time what do you think uh is the
one day
i do a thing where i don't brush my
teeth until i leave the house i also
don't shower until i leave that sure
that's normal um
even wait when you get up you don't want
to have fresh breath and
nah who am i judging i guess i know you
just went four days and you're judging
me for not having fresh breath in the
morning i wasn't at the house i was in a
hotel room in the most glamorous city in
the world
meeting [__] famous people oh yeah
that's going to keep me from [__]
being cool out there oh we were going to
let him into the playboy man
yeah i mean it's not that he's wearing
pajamas and 900 pounds
3.88
um yeah a day i guess if you're doing
something
camping
camping here i mean we were like a
five-star hotel you're comparing that to
camp you're in combat uh yeah stuff like
that coma maybe
[Laughter]
the other side of darkness you know i
don't know
purgatory i respect a good coma um
i don't know
yeah that's too long that's two but dude
we were at 7 11 together we went to like
multiple places all right we went to the
place where i bought the toothpaste
we hate lunch at cvs
we were at it but he
yeah uh yeah that's a little uh i got to
do that
asap
that's the sign of pure garbage yeah
when's the last time you were at the
dentist
which is weird because i know i got
cavities in there i should be that's how
they end up as root canals i should be
an agonizing thing that is they like
cavities go they just [__] get down
on the gum root canals are a scam anyway
do you get a root out canal two's
falling out in a couple of months or in
a couple years they uh they never left
jesus they never last root canals don't
work what do you want from me who says
that a lot of people
six out of ten dennis
three out of ten mechanics
yeah 10 out of 10 dirt bags say root
canals yeah it's a [__] scam yeah but
i got to go get my teeth cleaned uh-huh
find out what's going on in there
sure yeah go for it [__] take a look
at it i've i mean i've mentioned the
last one i went to my my girl bought me
on groupon and that was about four years
ago
guy guy trying to sell me on a [__]
periodontist program and he had a
mouthful of braces guy in a petco
[__] going to work on you yeah couple
of greenies in your mouth
dude h the h foley paranoia comes
through again root canals often fail
which require the same painful and
expensive procedure to be done on the
same tooth over and over yup goddamn
right i know they're coming for us
kidding me what year did you graduate
dirtbag university
he got his masters and that's how they
get you you can read all this in my new
book that's how they get you uh
there's a book in the future for us
probably a book simon schuster one of
you call me man i wanted to maybe say
this for hard feelings or something uh i
hope she doesn't mind that i'm putting
her on blast
but um your mom can't read
[Laughter]
you're good
you're not far off i'll tell you that
right now um
i was i was with my niece and nephew uh
last weekend and they're even young kids
they're they're instead of being in the
car on their phones and stuff they're
reading and they're reading like books
books like you know they like it
my niece goes back there in the back she
gets situated she's cranking out this
book
and it started started a conversation uh
with my mom because like my nephew's
like you guys aren't really big readers
on your side my sister-in-law's family
they're all readers
i'm not a big reader
and i said i was like i mean i lie to
people and say that like i've read books
and i recommend i recommend books that i
haven't read i've admitted that uh but i
asked my mom i was like how many books
she my mom said she's never read a book
a full book in her life not even
angela's issues that was real big with
every dirtbag irish family angel is
issues well i read most of the secret
yeah that was another one too the secret
they're [__] they're trying to bang
carmen a lecture or something what was
it angels with filthy angels and demons
oh that was the tom
hanks it wasn't something based on that
yeah uh the da vinci
that might as well be [__] devil
propaganda in my house
get the [__] out of here that goes
straight to confession we boycotted tnt
for a year
[Laughter]
[__] heathens over there
none of this is true by the way
my tom hanks my mom was throwing [__]
holy water at the tv
never watching big again i'll tell you
that
no [__] yeah i turned my head around
just to freak her out patty's
you're hanging off the ceiling
what's for
dinner giffy's not here right now
ah yeah patty's never read a book we
usually don't have this much fun after
we spent a week together too
yeah what a good time
but patty's never read a book i've never
really read a book we're not big readers
my dad read like liar's poker like a
couple of minutes ago they tried to scam
his buddies
read phil hellmuth's book
how to win with a pair of deuces
is that a real book
[Laughter]
how to win it all with two pair huh
that's gonna be our book
how to blow it at the tables
holy [__]
the kevin ryan story
oh man we stink
so yeah um how was that this is also a
little more hard feelings but i want to
um when we were out there we went to uh
mel's diner
los angeles where the stars eat
that place
talk about a sticky menu
oh you're running three stooges all
right
i'll take more water
he's the later no um
so we're at mel's diner we got time to
kill before we go this is very hard
feelings but um i wanted to give our so
we're sitting there
and waiter comes over young kid
uh i go sweetheart i go hey can i get a
i get a
bacon and cheese omelet and he goes yeah
and he's like fun he's doing doing the
ipad and he goes uh
all right so i got a ham omelette let's
go i could have a bacon a bacon he
brought me chinese food
bake i go bacon he goes okay and i go i
thought he hated us and then he goes do
you want any cheese with your ham and
bacon omelette i'm like no no no just
and i'm literally in my head i'm like
this guy stinks i'm like i'm about to
change tables and he goes guys i'm sorry
i'm really nervous i'm a huge fan and we
were like oh
[__] i felt good man but i ended up
being [__] johnny on a spot with the
diet cokes too david dave shout out to
david shout out to him out there working
uh pursuing acting yup young actor out
there in hollywood making a go of it
hustler good kid shout out to that mel's
diner not too shabby
we had another way around
though that's good stuff yeah let's get
to some cues there kippy let's do it
guys when you join the old uh patreon
there uh you get to ask a garbage
question on air yeah that's where we're
at that's where we're at right now i
mean a big man go don't we chop them up
they're good time lay it on me go ahead
all right this one
this one
this one's from austin first time long
time never have one red there you go are
you garbage if you open a can of soda
with your teeth
i can feel that i used to do that like
exclusively i don't know about that but
i know you're getting laid i'll tell you
that right now that's a smooth move that
pairs with a giant oily sandwich in the
other hand yeah like you yeah you're
doing it because you don't got a free
hand wait a can
yeah ah no
bottle
bottles cool
who's what a beer bottle no one's a kid
no one's drinking bottles of soda you
kind of have a nice stewards or
something hanks shout out to hank
got root beer twist off those yeah
that's true
you don't remember the police do you are
you too young for that what when you
when the thing came off the can
like the whole thing like a can of beans
no
what do you mean no the okay soda cans
it used to come off like a tab yeah like
the thing would you would be able to rip
it off the whole top no no not the whole
time all right i'm asking the little
[__] thing with the little mouthpiece
that you pop
the mouth yeah the the tab yes well the
tab used to
come off and you'd flick they come off
now after a little bit of work no this
thing the whole thing would just peel
off
you don't remember that immortalizing
the jimmy buffett song stepped on a pop
top come on now is that what that is
that's what's called crop top
uh
yeah i used to do that you see that with
beers too a lot like coors lights like
playing [__] when you're like
reorganizing the beer pong table or
something you're like [__] jesus yeah
i can feel the [__] blood running
like the
yikes i don't like metal on my teeth no
that's what you feel do you ever bite
into a piece of foil left over on like a
kitkat or something yeah whoo send it to
the moon
that cotton balls i can't [__] with
cotton balls you have cotton balls
sounds like a dj it gives me the [__]
heebie jeebies yeah man that's [__]
trash but it's pretty cool
um yeah of course anything like that
it's kind of badass you know what i mean
yeah even opening up a bottle with the
lighter that's pretty cool give me that
thing i can't do that
on the edge of the table you can do that
i have i can't i'm not like looking cool
i remember i tried to look cool doing
that at my coffee table my mom
partying with your mom i was just trying
to be cool she had brought in like root
beers or something what's up nailed this
broadway what do you want from me get a
lot of ass
dad was at work how about the moves
um
all right this is from scootsie
doubleday that's a very deep cut of a
name
scootsie doubleday uh how many tic tacs
are you eating at a time oh that's a
great question um if it's the orange or
fruity ones the whole thing's getting
whacked okay yes of course orange
doesn't stand a chance how many are you
at a time though like
a mouthful yeah so you're going mouth
with the orange ones
the orange ones are the fruity ones i
understand mouse yeah yeah yeah and even
though
green green light green winter green
dark rings i see rocks that's for four
people what is the dark green ones or
the white ones white ones were new
monsters one of my secretary dark greens
we were light winter green my dad had
about six packs of them in the car at
all times winner i put wintergreen in a
different category than peppermint
wintergreen is much more candyish to me
shout out to the wooden green lifesaver
that sparks when the lights are off and
you chew it in your mouth what you
didn't know that
sets off a spark
when you're chewing winter go ahead yeah
i see you [__] on your keyboard
looking it up you want to test me again
is that like intentional or that's just
like maybe you're radioactive no that's
was the thing you would turn the lights
out and put me do they have i'm saying
do they advertise that though it's like
a party in your mouth no i'm asking if
they don't advertise it you're creating
electric charge kids are shocking
themselves it's a happy accident he's
right i believe i never i never doubted
you sounds like you did no i just didn't
know what you i wasn't sure if they were
like it was like a you know
[__]
it's a side effect okay from the
chemicals that's not a word yeah it is
all right now
[__] up in the lab um gamma radiation
but i see those differently is what i
was saying either even the winter green
middle yeah i would i would i would
throw orange ones i don't understand why
the orange ones are the only ones that
are chewy
i don't know either why is that yeah
it's whack
the fruity ones sometimes i think they
sit longer maybe
no it's how they're made they're so good
nothing tastes like an orange tic-tac
it's true you know what i don't kick out
of bed either the fruity certs it's a
little old-school i don't think i
remember those you weren't a search guy
oh it was huge shirts winter green
peppermint yeah they are the fruity ones
those are those those are solid center
solids yeah there was like it was like a
lifesaver but they were filled no those
are
certs are you sure positive oh yeah yeah
yeah there was no hole i thought you
were thinking of breath savers because
they had the extra little bit little
blue in the center that extra kick of uh
breath freshener that wasn't breath
savers was it yeah it was breath savers
kit let's talk about ladder love that
ladder let's talk about ladder baby gang
you don't want to leave your family
holding the [__] bag nope you got
chest pains you got bad knees you got
[__] tingling in your toes i got it
all do yourself a favor get over there
the ladder get yourself what they call a
little term life insurance so you're not
getting [__] buried in a frigid air
box in the backyard
life's fragile baby you gotta take you
gotta you gotta make the right moves now
to set people up in the future live for
today yeah what okay ladder's 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for three
million in coverage or less just answer
a few questions about that your health
in an application three million you
could go real far down in south america
you just need a few minutes a phone a
laptop to apply ladder smart algorithms
work in real time so you'll find out if
you're instantly approved no hidden fees
canceled at any time there you go refund
there you go if you change your mind in
the first 30 days okay uh
finally since life insurance cost more
as you age now is the time to cross it
off your list make a move so go to
ladderlife.com today to see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life dot com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it mint mobile
mint mobile know it love it use it of
course got a lady friend i'll call my
girl right now she's got mitt mobile 15.
the sound is 15 a month you know why why
cut out the middleman cut out the bozo
get ripped off by big wireless kick rock
yeah no [__] take your towers and beat
it
whatever they have sure do yourself a
favor get over to [__] mint mobile 15
plans they got starting there no
middleman it's the first company to go
completely
online what's the catch there is no
catch cue ball what'd i tell you i got a
[__] sweet deal for you i know they
cut out the cost of retail stores and
pass those sweet savings right onto you
for anyone who hates their phone bill i
know i do mint mobile's all for premium
wireless for just 15 beans look at that
mint mobile gives you the best rate
whether you're buying one one or four a
family at mint family started just two
lines ryan reynolds
all plans
all plans come with a limited talk in
text high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network if you use your phone with any
mint mobile plan you keep your same
number along with your existing contacts
there you're not starting from scratch
like these other bozos oh changing your
number like
yeah [__] talk about letting the heat
the heat cool off for a little bit
switch to mit mobile get a premium
wireless service start at just 15 bucks
a month uh to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and then get
that plan shipped to your door for free
look at that go to mint mobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cart your wireless build at 15 bucks a
month mobile.com scarborough do it do it
breath savers my dad was ever a
binocular guy for a minute
yeah it wasn't good plus you get in your
eyes and [__]
it was real trashy my experience with
anaka is exclusively throwing them into
fires yeah that was big
you almost had to go like the seedy part
of town to get it
holy [__] real five-star athlete over
here
why is that athlete
real busy on a friday night in high
school huh let's go birds go birds and
breath
fires were big at a time fires were huge
the [__] hairspray and the lighter
man the first time i did that was like
holy [__] it was one of those things you
were like wow this really worked sure
right jesus christ yeah [__] [__] in
your pants wild look out that and
ringing a lighter was always a good time
yo yeah
[__] portrait still it caught your
eyebrows yeah it looks like aj running
around um the whole thing the whole
thing
with the with the with the with the
orange ones and the fruity ones and i'm
i'm knocking them back as if they were
nerds yeah i think the gentlemen think
yeah they're not nerds the gentleman
thing to do is
put them in your hand
um
yeah that's a try never because anyhow
you want some after you were just oh
never no all in your mustache and stuff
there's pubes in your [__] tic tac
holder get out of here
the gentleman thing to do is have them
in the cup holder in your car and hey
when you're getting out to go close a
deal yeah or go hit on some answers what
i've done this is a real classy move
people probably a lot of people probably
do it out there
is not brush your teeth for four days
matt um
if you go into like uh they have them
everywhere now but they kind of started
it like staples and [__] is the [__]
the big big tubs of gum
that go that go in the console yes
they go in the cup holder you know what
i stumbled across in the middle of the
night what's that those [__] ice
cubes
the gum cubes they're all right they got
eggs they saw just someone someone had
them delicious the texture of those
things oh it might have been me because
i got i got a wintergreen pack in the
car i don't eat stuff that you have i
asked you that the other day if i ever
cooked anything would you ever would you
ever eat anything i cooked
i don't think so you said no i said i
don't see where i would be in a
situation where that would happen but
i'm gonna when we go camping i'm gonna
work the grill you'll eat that
i don't agree with either one of those
statements that you just made some pizza
guys shows up yeah
uh yeah i don't i don't know i don't
know i mean it'd be different
throwing a hot dog on a [__] grill is
one thing you know mixing up
potato salad's different let's say you
had a potluck or something like that and
i showed up with something where you
didn't get to see me prepare it there's
no there's no reality where i go to a
[__] potluck and eat food from a
bunch of strangers you're crazy
no way
yeah especially one that you're also
invited like that's nuts i've done them
for like super bowl parties and stuff
like that with you know
loose acquaintances but never
also what do you make what do i do a lot
of stuff like scrambled eggs
show up to a [__]
potluck with [__] scrambled eggs with
a couple of shells in there
snot sliders booger burgers whatever you
need
belly button lint parfaits
who wants more toenails uh
yeah no i mean i've seen boogers on you
more than i've you know i'm too much
okay
i don't think yeah i don't think you
know i don't think you passed the
[__] health and safety code either
you're entitled to your opinion
did you just check yourself for boogers
i think he did i think he did and he
looked like i pulled one there earlier
is it still there that's how he starts
shooting off at the mouth
make sure i'm booger free
you got me dead the rights no boogers on
me i'll tell you that right now
there's
yeah i mean there's probably about i
would say there's probably about
a coin flip 50 chance that there's
either boogers or booger residue on you
at any given probably it would be on my
pants by my pockets if i sneeze that's
where i keep them
[Laughter]
and transport them later no if i'm if i
sneeze in my hand then i'm jammed up
yeah we were in a we were in the uber
in an uber the other day on the way to
the airport i think
and man you were hocking [__] you
were sneezing like people were sitting
on [__] mortars
ah
dude the guy was swerving every time he
did it i thought we were getting
attacked dude you sneeze
so violently and they're so wet sounding
i don't know if they are but they're wet
sounding
sounds like someone's throwing gak
against the wall
i could do a thing too if i'm laying
there and i'm bored
um where i'll stick my finger all the
way up my nose my pinky and i'll rub the
inside of my thing just to get a couple
of sneezes
it feels good it's almost orgasmic when
you sneeze that was like the big
that was like the big wives style if you
could sneeze toby's got his finger up
his nose there's no way that that makes
you sneeze
ah i'm surrounded by boogers dude dude
my my my pinky's up there dude i got no
you got to lift up a little piece of
cartilage and rub it on there
i'll show you how it's done come over to
my house later this weekend you just get
like a really good sneeze it feels good
like you need to get that scissors are
great um
well there was that old wives house you
sneezed like eight times in a row it was
the equivalent of an orgasm or something
i can see that i can see that
yeah
sometimes orgasms it just doesn't say
sometimes they're really good sometimes
they're not but a sneeze is always
a-okay
you hear that folks
get yourself some pepper wash your
couple of drinks both of you wash your
hands i want some tic tacs now i'll tell
you that oh god he's got candy on her
brain i do that's how i get around it um
all right this one's from you got
another thing coming nice uh new 45
dollar homie what the [__] 10 tier 35
dollar overdraft
[Laughter]
oh man if your shit's getting
overdrafted for patreon
good piece of business i salute you sir
send us an email we'll send you a pack
of cards or something or some koozies uh
trying to make up for it his question is
a garbage if your girlfriend's meth head
cousin bought a horse with a stimulus
check p.s he's homeless
how much a horse has to be more than
twelve hundred bucks no maybe not you
could probably get an old nag for sure
about that you're not getting something
for the breeders cup yeah no you can buy
important you're not going to descend in
a smarty generation he has a horse on
craigslist
yeah let's see oh let's get into horse
racing
okay
not like anything prime time you know
local stuff
just around the neighborhood yeah street
stuff
let's go let's go run quarter miles down
by the airport
on my philly drag racing
what do you got t-bone what can i get a
what can you get me in a you know get me
a stallion for or a donkey
i think that's the wrong kind of way all
right all right yeah category uh do we
want just
sort by price descending
you have to be a little more specific
something i can pull a plow
okay
okay like a horse a standardized yeah
there are there there's like literally
80 types of hunting horse jumping horse
polo
trotting vaulting
cow horse breeding we're trying to [__]
this thing
let's start with buy a horse and expect
to pay between 100 to 10 grand
let's each get horses 100 yeah you could
get a horse for a hundred bucks
probably not great probably seen some
[__] probably in a stew
just they show it with a bag of
meatballs
the average cost of a hobby horse maybe
that's what we need a hobby horse is
three g's
8 500 five g's
couple g's we can get
steve what's a hobby this one's 578
but or best offer 500
that's like an old jeep
they just have it standing out on the
grass in front of the house
next to a corolla
[__] ah man you gotta have a place but
these people obviously live in a rural
area rural yeah with a meth prevalent
also think about it though
i guess the upkeep of a horse but that's
pretty smart
you buy a horse
get around town go meet your dealer
using that you can't use it like that
why not because that's more upkeep too
you think gas is expensive you know how
much oats cost
i don't plus you got a place
oats it's probably grass i wonder where
they have it
it's probably i mean people in north
philly have them
like proper like they're called they're
called like the cowboys but they they
have philly i know we've talked they
have barns though somewhere no they're
like kept in like abandoned
empty lots
not they can't be outside in the winter
and stuff they got to have some type of
shelter for it yeah
jesus i'm telling you man
out there trotting down broad street
[__] flexing on these [__] dmx
blasting i like it
i'm all about it django unchained dance
yeah i don't know uh
you ever been on a horse yeah
better than a horse
been a horse a few times okay my boy
used to be a horse fan
my boys parents did really well and they
lived uh in a stable they lived on it
they had like a little like
a lot of land plot nice plot of land
they had like a north 40 and all that
[__] um maybe not that much but they
had a few acres up front a few acres in
the back and they they ran the horses at
the devon horse show they were like real
hoity-toity so we used to have to clean
you know it was like a thing you were
just a lowly stable boy yeah uh-huh
caught after googling googling at the
the owner's daughter i'm sure too caught
after dark in a rainstorm
made love that night gippy being an old
bronco
me and here comes sunshine
now yeah we used to [__] ride them we
used to run them around we used to you
know what's a good time that we should
do
go out to the [__] go out to belmont
yeah play the ponies live races sure
they're a [__] hoot sure you know
what's a great name for a for a horse
aunt toddy's basement and it's on
toddy's basement coming around to the
last leg and hoodie
toddy's play or something toady's a
great word for that voice here comes
teddy here comes hoodie there you go and
here comes teddy coming around there
she's three fur long's back
with a marlboro 650 hanging out of her
mouth making it really good i've never
seen a horse with a man that fat run
that fast but we gotta do something we
gotta we gotta adjust
we gotta invest put you in a chariot be
like the coliseum
we gotta uh we gotta invest in some sort
of something like that a horse i told
you laundry mats no something something
that competes
all right you know what i mean something
like a little league team how about
highlight here that's real crooked yeah
[__] pay somebody off
something like that if there's a team or
some sort of something we could sponsor
find some cuban guy down in miami
that'll play ball what what would we
really up our alley is if we could
sponsor like a dart team or like a
bowling team no but i want something i
want something a little cool i'd like
little league
little league's not bad
getting a little league we have
potentially could get to the little
league world series kind of in then
we're owners you have an in over there
said i'm kind of in that's a good idea
that or like a pee wee hockey team might
be fun there you go yeah teams are early
get some scouts [__] start drafting
kids from different area codes go up to
[__] alberta or something nova scotia
yeah pick them where they're growing you
know feel like adam sandler in the
hustle we just were talking about that
great movie got to do something like
that something we can rally really all
get behind
donors boosters paying off refs
plus the concession stands build our own
state slurpee's alone
you're back there
i would be backed i'd work a snack bar
but i'm gonna own a stadium we could
though that was i remember reading an
article back in the day where you could
buy like
it doesn't cost a whole bunch of money
to buy like a sports team in like mexico
or something you know what i mean like a
third like a [__] real lowly team
some ugandan lacrosse team yeah
something like that get it cook it
these guys are killing it we can be we
could be the boot we could be working
the booth we could be calling the games
or like like how bert and tom have a
race car what about what all the uh
golfers are getting in trouble for the
liv league or something like that
there's saudi league those saudis are
throwing a little bit of cash out there
they're paying everybody 150 mil i ain't
got that kind of money
i'd have to move a few things around
[Laughter]
hey listen phil best i can do the own a
helix mattress by any chance do you want
one
i'm getting rid of mine
um
yeah
i'm with it those saudis are really
really power play over there
trying to stay off their radar
those boys don't play nice hey i am not
a reporter moving forward not a lot of
warning shots
no they play for keeps those saudis
they play to win
whoever lowest under par gets the
um
all right let's see this is from tyler
not a question but after my cousin makes
a sandwich he uses a piece of deli meat
to wipe the mayo off the knife and
refers to it as a meat rag
[Laughter]
i respect ivory the meat rags are tough
look just do it and don't tell people no
the j well it's not going back in the
mayo i understand what he's saying this
but i understand i'm saying the name
meat rag is a tough look the gentleman's
moves to do that on the bread and it
works really nice yeah you don't give me
a lick as you throw it in the sink or
whatever oh straight mayo i'm surprised
no not mayo peanut butter
peanut butter and turkey hummus sounds
like a name of a band toby's into
did you get the new meat rag lp i'm
going to the character tonight we're all
sleeping out
we're just a bunch of meat heads
[Music]
straight the other one's going to the
concert
you're the one camping out
and we're back kip let's talk about
upside uh get upside baby get upside
cause there's a downside and we're in a
downside right now inflation's through
the [__] roof gas astronomical all
right shit's all over the world [__]
falling apart
all right got these commies coming at us
left and right the little man's getting
screwed out here little man's getting
screwed trying to weasel out the middle
class but it ain't gonna happen and you
can make sure it doesn't have one upside
because guess what you get cash back
with your groceries with your gays maybe
it's your night out dining out dying it
out like a
is the name of the game now i'm not
talking about cash back when you go to
cvs and buy batteries like a loser and
ask for a 20. i'm talking about making
your purchases work for you yes with
upside
it's not too good to be true to get
started download the free upside app in
the app store or to google play use our
promo code garbage and get five dollars
or more cash back when you purchase your
f first ten dollars or more
that's easy easy next claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on upside
checking at the business pay as usual
with the credit or debit card and get
paid uh in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with upside
they know what they're doing over there
at upside so get involved you can cash
out any time to your bank paypal or an
e-gift card for amazon or other brands
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week holy cannoli
that's the turkey nothing to shake a
stick at that's probably why they have
4.8 star rating in the app store
download the free upside app
and use promo code garbage to get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more that's
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
using promo code garbage do it now back
to that show back to the show um
this one's from trevor never have one
read devices that help you chug a beer
faster yay or nay i.e
shotgun tools etc etc etc i like shotgun
and a good beer i think that's a good
time
that's pretty cool i used to [__] them
up left and right stabbed the key in
there [__]
be all over me uh it's cool
you do them real quick
t-bone's going to be very opinionated on
this so everybody strap in
if you're shotgun and beers you can't
have any sort of tool made for
you can't have any kind of fun doing it
it's real serious
no the it's the most fun to do it but
you gotta you gotta be using household
stuff pocket knife butter knife key a
bottle opener like they use the top of a
fence something uh your thumb is the
best one that's
that's dangerous it's not it's so tight
uh i think we always just use like a key
or something like that like you know a
house key of some sort yeah i was never
huge on your thumb we were a beer
wolverine what are you doing
what yeah it's yeah exactly the thumb
gun also known as the renegade it's the
best party trick known to man
guys watch out i'm gonna do the renegade
no no no then we're gonna go to the meat
rack this party has three dudes in it by
the way oh yeah one of them's in the
shower
the other one's a cat so every party
you've been to has been catered by your
mom shut up shout out to patty's shout
out to patty's
he's also 50. i mean is there an insult
coming there somewhere
yeah the broad puts out a good cuddy i
don't need to tell
if you stifle the attitude lose the lip
maybe you'll get a couple
with a little cranberry sauce and
coleslaw that's how we do it um keep it
real trashy no marinara in our house
beer bonds there's it's time and place
for that you know what i mean you can't
be [__] the only acceptable time it
would be for me to like do a beer bong
at this age i feel
as a dirtbag who likes the booze on your
way to jail
uh if you're at like a tailgate
and there's like the group next year
you're working deep cover and now
everyone's gonna be like a bunch of
young kids or something like hey ol you
know you you know yeah i'll do one
[__] throw my hat in the ring for old
time's sake frank the tank frank the
tank exactly um
but like you got to be in your early
trying to keep these kids you're not
beating them up oh i'm doing here
fresh um other than that yeah it's very
limited you know you shouldn't be just
doing no i'm not at 35 or 36 or whatever
you guys are yeah you can't be doing it
i do like i used to [__] crush a beer
bunker no gravity balls so [__] good
it's all right sticking your head in the
sink
one of those is set you straight i mean
you also can't you should be doing those
after 22 either what gravity bungs well
if you're not cool sure a couple of
bangers
[Music]
[__] put you out
[__] you up real nice uh we were heavy
beerbong cruise and then you would like
always had one someone had one in the
trunk or whatever all or you'd [__]
everybody bring it into the bar with you
that was crazy yeah a couple of dudes do
that
sneak him under the table
we get a kid that used to show up
everywhere we went with a fifth the
[__] uh
uh bacardi or captain morgan's and just
buy sodas and [__]
i'm not paying that kind of money for
these drinks be like nickel shot night
yeah
yeah real trash i think it's trashy
captain morgan's is trashy isn't he
captain morgan captain morgan yeah give
me captain morgan's yeah well captain
morgan's rum theoretically
i'll have a captain morgan on the rocks
would be the gentleman's way even then
you're still trash and what's trash here
captain morgan's or malibu oh oh oh my
god
i've been [__] up on malibu before
getting [__] out of it it was like i've
been to the bahamas once oh dude i got a
whole [__] plantation a [__]
pineapple in me that coconut can kick
[__] love it rocks dude i love it i
remember my dad's [__] perfume i
remember my dad making his virgin pina
coladas when we were kids and we love
them little dirt balls every once in a
while break out the blender instead of
dessert he'd make us a pina colada jesus
christ
no booze in it
or maybe
probably felt really trying to put you
to sleep and throw the moves at your mom
hey patrick the fat one's
snoring i yeah i hooked him up to a
sleep apnea machine
uh gave him a couple of blue hawaiians
and sent him off to bed
yeah no we were capped captain all like
i feel like each one of those in your 20
or like teens the 20s you know had a run
right like you had a year where captain
yeah captain get a bottle of captain
sure cheap pocket was big you kids with
the pinnacle and the flavored [__]
vodkas that was we never thought
yeah no we never [__] with the cotton
candy the whipped cream that [__] was
always smirnoff kicked that off
yeah in my day it was [__] chair
smearing or uh what is it stoli razz
stolen stoli was it stole the orange
rat
[__] it no
get me a bottle of e and j and let's
call it a [__] day stoli razz stully
razz and sprite who uh little urchin
jerker do you write what do you think is
trash here captain and coke or the seven
and seven
captain and coke seven gentlemen was
introduced to me as a gentleman's dream
yeah really yeah i mean i'm a from a
dirtbag family but i was at a vfw for
someone's communion party or graduation
party and my uncle was drinking seven
and sevens with a twist of lemon yeah
and i was ordering them yeah back in the
day seven up was like it was like ginger
ale it was a little bit like seagram's
gin isn't it secrets yeah that's called
i mean that's glass it's canadian yeah
it's important
it comes in a glass [__] jug a handle
[__] real nice
segregation what else is pretty classy
v.o
my stepdad's dad used to drink vo
straight out of a red solo cup and he
would look at you and go get me one of
these and he meant one of these my aunt
colleen was a big v.o
theo and jim poor in that forum at like
13 but she loved it it's like turpentine
she's like secret seven too i believe um
yeah you ever [__] with amaretto when
you were when you were young
on a rocks ah no they used to say
decerono and coke it tastes just like dr
pepper
[__] decorations give me a [__]
coors light let's call it a [__] day
um
no but we did do like the
yes
captain with captain co captain and
ginger was all right it's like a [__]
creamsicle
[__] teeth anything with sodas
[__] trash
yeah it's trash high balls they called
them
that's a real yeah give me a high ball
real garbage i think high ball was in
the the glass the glass yeah eyeball
take a high ball that was paddy's move
uh-huh she likes a g and t as well yeah
she does she's like a gin and tonic
he'll put one back um no high balls just
uh
whiskey and soda with a lemon
oh yeah i think or ginger ale or ginger
beer my bad i think they misused it back
then they just assumed that it was all
the same thing i think i'm off to i
think i'm off beer this summer and my
drink is uh whiskey sodas
not clubs yeah like with a whiskey soda
okay with like
like a
lemon or a lime or something drinking
though you were drinking those white
claws
which are [__] garbage which is the
classiest way to drink malt liquor yeah
they don't make you feel good it's not
after
like i feel pretty [__] up like you
just said chemo
yeah it's not fun i said there's not
enough gatorade in the world to come
back from the white cloth
no [__] you drink 20 of those you're out
of commission you've got to be hooked up
to an iv yeah change the oil
those things stink you guys ever have
sparks
back in the day
no that was an energy drink though right
it was the it was one of the og energy
and alcohol energy and multiple people
drinking that
before loco yeah we couldn't get back a
couple of those
those things will get you across the
river
security deposits due to [__] four
logos oh man
shout out to my stepdad who kept it
find yourself on the south end of an
eight ball [__] pick up the phone and
dial four loco i'll tell you that right
now
tell me we need to lift the [__]
nightlight land man
dude they dropped jammed up i was
probably 20.
watermelon and lime to get their ass
over here
those things came in like [__] it like a
wrecking ball they were outlawed for a
minute right they toned down the
caffeine or something dude they would
change people
it was like bad i remember looking at my
buddy pat who just wasn't there one
night like i was like talking and i was
just like you are another guy like prop
not like black out drunk all right pick
him up like he was like a man possessed
two of those in a full moon the village
the villagers would be chasing you
like the torches boys
uh those were um
a wild introduction at that eight in my
early twenties of just like
[__] ruining things that was like
when elvis [__] came out they were
worn in pair don't touch that forelock
devil's juice
makes me move my hips in a weird way
like forrest gumps [__] with my legs
going yeah that [__] really [__] i
remember man i had like one instance
where i was like i woke up i'm like oh
no the lights went out before i left the
[__] the lights are not the pre-game
that's bad i don't remember going to the
bar you go with your clothes and a
hanger i don't know what's going on
school bus out front
that was trashy uh
i was just talking to my wife about this
the other day uh we used to rent a
school bus
to go from
the burbs down to the city when we were
like you know 20 21 22. was somebody was
this someone saying patrick's day no
that was already expressed
buddy that's a good that's a good they
do that all over is that just a trashy
philly thing no it's probably i don't
you couldn't do it in new york listener
on st patrick's day a bunch of dirt
balls all rent [__] school buses and
go down it's like a thing it's like an
organized thing like 30 bars take part
in it and then there's like i don't know
30 school buses that just 50 fights 70
breakups oh man
150 000 crying ladies
i remember a bunch of dudes looking to
tune somebody up we were on the back of
one and
uh
yeah whatever we'll move forward
no uh we set a fire
not jesus
what is he gonna come looking for you
you [__] bubble gummer
you think the feds are listening no
hey remember that fat kid that set the
back seat on fire somebody a kid like
left their homework or something or left
a book or something and someone let it
on fire and threw it out the window and
it landed like wait you you rented an
actual school bus that was in use that's
what we were showing jesus christ
there's a couple of kids we had to make
the stops
man i've never seen four kids gonna get
that's that i never thought about that
i'm on my way to fourth grade with my
fruit roll up in my sandwich talking to
my best friend there's a guy finger
popping his [__]
yeah that's the sunday before yeah
that's jesus that was the shocking
revelation to us i thought they were
sold off after they rained they were
like
like rent a car they had to be up monday
morning and start cooking same driver
you think i don't know probably picked
up weekend shifts oh we knew a guy who
had a bus i think he worked for the boss
that's never a good no and he would get
you on a discount be like 300 bucks
or 250 bucks plus you had to tip him 50
to get down there
what a [__] scumbag
but you know you get 30 40 people on a
bus
no nobody's drinking and driving you
[__] pull a keg on there for 50 like
a keg of [__] natty for 50 bucks
and everybody throws up like 20 30 bucks
these are underage kids no we were over
i mean i'm sure there was a couple of
[__] dingers in there
the kid with the homework i guess a
couple over achievers no we were all
hammered fourth grader like this [__]
at home rooms really gave me a hard time
yeah we were all like 21 yeah you guys
want to see me set my lunch box on fire
uh yeah it's a uh tough look please
figure blasting some broad
that's terrible
it's a family show kevin i'm done you're
the one doing i hear about you and your
dirt ball buddies
beer bongs are trash yeah that's what i
said all started yeah it did gravity
bongs
all right this one's from janky never
had one red do you have any jeans with
paint on them
i wish i did i don't anymore but that
was a big
i think if you were working construct
like even your nice jeans at some point
get worn out get [__] up that was cool
though
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be tight
i don't have any jeans
i have a couple of i have a couple
little wishlist pairs up in the up in
the closet uh-huh waiting to break those
things how far do you think you're away
we got a long long way what are they
like 38 or something it'll be cold
outside i can tell you that and i ain't
talking about that's going to freeze
over
global warming summer of 2028.
we've slided into those things
yeah
um all right this one's from mavi
uh
does your family stand for the national
anthem when they're watching the games
on tv
no
um
does your dad take a hat off if he's
wearing no hats in the house no hats
inside he's a serviceman
no we wear our hats inside [__]
commie
pinko best that's got nothing to do with
the flag yeah it's service
what are you talking about your only
servicemen allowed to wear their hats
inside i believe that's just it's a
servicing no hats inside is a thing from
the the armed military i thought it was
just out of respect for the restaurant
to not wear a hat no no hats inside so
tony soprano said
so you take it up with him uh i believe
it yo it's definitely a military thing i
didn't know that yeah yeah yeah no we
wear hats inside he'll take his hat if
the national anthem is on
he'll take his hat off though if he's
watching it on tv he won't stand up i
thought he's out doing the flag in the
morning at 21 gun salute he's doing taps
over in the corner
aren't they with the bugle
the neighbors are pissed
no no no but yeah we i would say i know
what you're getting at with the question
and yeah the foleys tend to lean a
little patriotic
i can tell you this on memorial day
every year you're watching gary sinise
for about 24 hours straight that guy
plays america's hits that guy's a
goddamn american right there shout out
to [__] lt dan
lieutenant first class whatever he's
[__] top shelf
that gary sinise really [__] does it
you know what's uh uh what just passed
memorial day right yeah that's what i'm
saying um they were crushing that they
might have
they they tear up during that
different different parts of that
i think they might stand up when they do
something on that not sure yeah 69.
watching the phillies get blown out
upstairs um
half a hoagie in me they have on the
george washington bridge they hang that
huge american flag everything's all
right i don't care if you're a terrorist
here in a sleeper cell that'll get you
[__] charged up when you cross the g
the [__] goddamn gwb pat in the
highlights oh buddy
you're a [__] you're you're usa usa
man that thing's like slowly it's the
size of a football it's awesome and it's
like slowly [__] whipping it's all
right yeah
two poor bastards got to put that thing
up man yikes yeah
we have that whole setup we got the
flags they got the flags they have the
light on the flag
go down that goes down the half mass
every once in a while for running low on
muffins or something
at any point in your life i pay the
comcast
we're out of ham drop the flag
let them know at any point in your life
did you have the tiny flags that go on
the window of the car they were big
dude after 9 11 what do you mean
everybody was driving around like they
were stone cold steve austin
are you kidding me that's not a thing
everybody [__] flags
there's america god damn [__] beers
are dropping staggers
a couple of bluebell diplomats rolling
around
on the front
yeah we're flags flags everywhere we got
like two or three flag boxes that he's
gotten throughout the years
um yeah of course of course yeah the
little mini flags that go on the [__]
desk
flags all day sure
do you think about enlisting after 9 11
i did how old were you uh i was young i
was probably i don't know 40 45.
that would have been last year idiot
i was going to sign up after the
pandemic
trying to get some bennies
you just need a fat guy or anything
trying to get this toe looked at
now
i did think about it at 11. it would
have been like 23 or something yeah 20
but i was like 300 pounds and i was a
[__] huge you were fat back then too
i was fat but i went through spurts i
was like nathan lane back then okay one
minute i'd be like [__] tight and the
next minute i'd blow up
tends to come that way what drug
addiction sure tend to fluctuate weight
uh-huh
on solid ground
yeah but now shout out to the guys that
did
shout out
um all right this one's from mark
uh uncooked hot dog straight out of the
package pass or play if you're nine
play
now that was my move saturday morning i
would get caught all the time my mom
would freak out no not going to be
touched on this before but never dude i
remember i saw my stepdad do it for the
first time when i was like 20 and i bet
to call the cops
you're gonna get sick my saturday
morning routine was i'd get up before
everybody else i'd go into the bathroom
i'd pee on the side of the toilet
so they don't hear you so they wouldn't
that's my game too you got to do that in
a one-bedroom apartment which i don't
think i would even have got in trouble i
was just a [__] weird kid and scared
and like riding the rail like yeah i
just i was sneaky wanted a sneaky
and i go into the thing yeah i get it
you're lying started at a young age
tell everybody i was doing homework
i got paperwork i'd go into the crisper
in the refrigerator where they kept the
hot dogs i take it from isn't that
reserved for vegetables not in our house
cured meats
i got grab i'd grab two no bun
go downstairs so i can have the dog with
me
give him his tribute throw on [__]
captain kangaroo whatever
the boss yeah keep him shot you got to
keep him quiet he starts crowning you're
a [__] you're jammed up daddy oh
broad's upstairs going for the alarm you
know what i mean
uh yeah now to eat my hot dogs
okay it'd be gross now
i would assume
maybe
i couldn't do it
something i wouldn't try
because sometimes i'm pretty loose i
think it gets rid of that
film
there's like a film like the juice the
water this there's a film and a smell to
an uncooked hot dog
you got to get rid of a sweat per se
yeah it it you gotta steam them it
hardens up into like bacon grease like
it's the same thing yeah it's the grease
on it that's like chalky at certain
temperatures i'm out you got to build
more than once i'm in a microwave like a
goddamn [__] gentleman man 30 seconds
and you're in dude i used to do two
oscar mayer cheese dolls for a minute
easy minute there was a button on my
mom's roof oh my mom's micro hit two in
for an easy minute fat ass button
fat [__]
popcorn oh fat pig here we go
and then while they were cooking i'd get
the rolls out because they'd be on a
paper plate get the rolls out pull that
plate throw them you'd have to stop it
like 57 because that 59 to 60. they
start [__] losing there was a window
yeah they'd be ever pull them out and
they're hard oh yeah jesus patty used to
really [__] do a number on us because
she kept the hot dog buns and hamburger
rolls in the freezer that [__] suck
and try you got a microwave and then
throw them in the the freezer to get
them trying to time that out throw them
in the toaster
you can never get the freezer smell off
dude it was like curing polio it was
[__]
balancing act in there
sometimes i would make cheese dogs with
just a [__] slice of like a craft
single if we just had regular diesel
sure [__] take two diesels throw i'd
take i'd break one craft single in half
throw it on air buddy you know you don't
got to explain it to me
been there good old days back when
living was easy huh
bro was a much simpler place back then
those oscar mayer cheese dogs man
something something about them they
don't do well on the grill they got they
got to be my microwaved yeah got to be a
little catchy maybe we'll do that for
our next patreon goal i just i eat a
couple hundred of
kobayashi some cheese dogs
dunking them in milk
dunking them
oh they say that's funny dunking on them
you dunk them
yo go down to the don come and get me
some donuts that was tough dunking
i can't do it you guys like donkey kong
[Laughter]
everybody on street rude uh this one's
from andy 10 homie never had a question
but the most popular homie by the way is
the ten dollar homie of course chicken
sandwich according to the nielsen
numbers
uh also all the 10 homes when i released
the hard feelings on youtube as a little
taste they were all like oh [__]
let these peasants know how we live on
the other side they were really going at
it a little cake for the masses
um
is it garbage if someone uses the same
unwashed container that the chicken was
marinated in as a serving platter if
you're a guest and witnesses what do you
do you [__] walk out
get the come on man
come on that's the same dirt bag that
[__] uh scrambles the eggs then
rinses it off with water and then throws
the throws that in there when you're
done cooking them that's how you get
salmonella's whoop salmonella no okay
that's insane there's a person in my
family that you gotta overlook a little
bit
while these tasks are you get
got to make sure they have a clean
serving tray because if they don't
you go how you get like
oh he'll be like ah just coming in for a
minute just throw him on there it's like
he he plays it real fast and loose with
the germs really yeah to the point where
like i'm like a sous chef i'm like here
he's [__] 15 clean plates what's 30.
i'm trying to get out ahead of him
i understand
trust me i'm well aware
i'm my parent my mom usually marinates
the chicken in a ziploc bag though we're
usually we're bag people oh yeah
marinating a zippy yeah for sure maybe
suck all the air out if you have one of
those sure
or the vacuum cleaner let the juices get
in there yeah no that's [__] that's a
d come on that's that's crossing the
line i'm aware that's just [__]
dangerous i'm aware so much so that like
we've had
had to prevent the person from cooking
it's been years but it's like all right
no more
hit the bricks that's my weakness raw
chicken i don't ask you how they want
your chicken done you're like what
[__] done that's how i want it no
easy minute for the chickie
[Laughter]
black and blue what do you think
[__]
sushi great give me the [__] burn it
[__] trust you
put some honey mustard on that [__] and
put it on the grill let that char get
after
cooking
let's see here
this one's for melanie
uh are you garbage if you burn your jet
ski to the ground instead of letting
them come repossess it
which i don't know who wins there
there's only a bunch of losers yeah
that's crazy isn't that arson
wouldn't there be more charges
i you know i don't think she's doing it
in the [__] sidewalk jesus or she's
right they're going to uh i don't know
if she did this this was her question
say it was stolen
how does that work
not from that specific thing but you're
you're a man of these things
so i don't know how that would work but
how do you do you lease a jet ski
yes they're going to repossess it yeah
so no that means you financed it
you're making payments on a loan i'm
sure you could probably lease a job i'm
sure there's some sort of company that
would lease the jet ski and turn around
and sell the used jet ski that's real
trash or you're making payments on it to
a bank
either way someone's coming to get it
burn it you say it was stolen i don't
think you would because you wouldn't be
made full
the financial institution whether it's a
lease or a bank who you lent the money
would be made whole again toby look that
up how do you commit jet ski fraud
first get a wetsuit you can lease a jet
ski my move would have been just to
anchor it in the middle of a lake
and just been like come and get it [__]
uh they'll go get it
yeah but they have jet skis yeah how do
you think they got where you think you
got your jet ski
these aren't jet ski less people
that's fair
i love how toby's like i'm going to get
the boat guy by going out
i would really [__] put it in the
woods yeah
send it to space do something yeah
like elon i know
how are we going to hide from these
people who clearly have boats
it is a wildly inconvenient thing unless
you have a boat sure
uh yeah you can lease from yamaha you
can lease from a lot of places it seems
a little vengeful to be honest with you
maybe there's is there some sort of jet
ski circuit we can get in and sponsor a
team that'd be pretty funny that would
be cigarette boat racing they'll also be
pretty good too
burning boats the cartels usually
i don't want to get it i don't want to
get in a [__] uh toe to toe with the
cartel or what i've heard they're going
to start working for them those are bad
hombres
move a couple of keys down there in the
islands
yeah you're hitting gravity bombs dude
yeah something couple of g bizzles
uh all right let's do one more and then
we'll get up at a h
[Music]
um
this one this is from james is it
garbage if your mother keeps every small
appliance in its original box for
example the breakfast griddle and
crock-pot both 15-plus years old are
kept in the original boxes yeah that's a
mom thing it's a mom thing through and
through yeah
i don't use it that much it doesn't go
in the regular cabinets it usually goes
in the wall in the closet in the front
where the coats on the floor of the
pantry yeah something yeah he can't have
they can't just have the george foreman
went back in sure daddy went back in
everything went back in the [__] box
yeah and as a younger kid
you ever have to go out to the garage
and get the serving [__] or whatever
[__] uh-huh i'm talking about ruining
thanksgiving
i have to look back you throw the turkey
out i'm not getting it i look back at
how lazy i was oh yeah as a 12 year old
the groceries we talked about i remember
taking dirt back to taking my dog out i
would be like it was it's like i
remember lying saying i did like i
[__] hated the [__] out of it
like i did ah god i take a god damn dog
first it was like i just had to open the
garage that's literally all i had to do
i still couldn't do it oh man the [__]
yeah all that [__] right back in the box
kept at night we had a can opener in a
[__] box for a long time the
automated can opener
i don't know why did it have the knife
sharpening wheel on the back no it's one
of those like it looks like a little
refrigerator that yeah that little one
yeah yeah a lot of times there's a wheel
on the back of those so you can sharpen
a knife
yeah which they need
my parents are all dull knives down here
yeah i like the dead rabbits it's
[__] bad
she needs something to sharpen that [__]
up yeah trying to cut a [__] sandwich
uh no bueno i just got a new set for the
apartment you did honey i'm cutting
through ginsu what'd you get yeah
i'm cutting through [__] every
goddamn thing really it's great got
finally got a pizza cutter too
game [__] changer
that's one of those things to me because
they weren't in that way we've talked
about this but when they were introduced
they must have been like 20 bucks and it
was like you don't spend 20 bucks on a
thing that a knife can already do like
we don't need that
but now they're like four dollars and
it'll be you can get like a pack of
three for four bucks and i'll be at your
house in 24 hours buddy i'm [__]
giving a dog haircuts with it and [__]
slicing the dice kippy scissor hands
over there
doing it nice all right let's wrap it up
we gotta go gang we [__] love you
love yous come see us under rude we'll
be on a road sign up for the patreon
sign up for the patreon subscribe on
youtube we got shirts available pick up
a shirt link in the description we also
uh go check if you're go subscribe to
the uh
clips channel
ayg clips new guy luke's taking over
that that thing's cooking go sign up for
that juice the numbers a lot of fun
stuff we love you we'll see you next
week peace